We're going to do that while we introduce graphics.
Remember our goal is to render a webpage to make a picture that corresponds
to a webpage.
That means we need some way to make a picture, and it may not be obvious
how we'll do that in Python.
It turns out that just as we used a library for regular expressions and parsing
and even timing procedures--if you remember that example from before--
we're going to use a library--someone else's code--to do graphics.
This ability, by the way, to build on existing off-the-shelf components
is one of the phenomenal advantages of computer science compared to
other parts of engineering.
It's very easy to copy someone else's library and build on top of it--
much harder to copy someone else's building without actually reconstructing it yourself.
So there are 4 key functions in our graphics library that are worth knowing about.
In graphics.word, you pass in a single word, and we'll draw it on the screen
or on the picture we're making for you.
Graphics.begtintag is a bit more complicated.
You have to tell us both the type of the tag and also any arguments it might have.
For example, suppose it's an anchor tag--a link in a webpage--
we need to know what the destination of the link is.
I'll have you pass that in as a dictionary, mapping href to "google".
Then after that you could call and display a bunch of other words
and those would all be underlined or they would show up in blue
or however we draw web links.
Eventually, we can end the most recent tag,
and there's also a way to display warnings, which is basically just for your benefit
if you're trying this out in later assigments.
This gives you a way of debugging.
Maybe this will show up in some bold, red color or something like that
so that you can't miss it.
So let's imagine that we have the following webpage input.
Nelson Mandela was elected democratically.
I'm going to show you the sequence of calls to the graphics library
that we would want.
Well, conceptually, the first thing we're going to do is print out the word Nelson
on the screen.
Then we'll want to print out the word Mandela on the screen.
Then we want to tell the graphics library that for while, subsequent words
should be bolded.
So we'll begin a bold tag.
This bold tag doesn't have any arguments, so we'll just pass in the empty dictionary.
That didn't actually draw anything on the screen.
It's just a note to begin drawing in bold.
You can imagine changing out your pen for something that draws in a different color.
Now we instruct our graphics library to write the word "was,"
but it's going to be bolded.
Now we write the world elected, and now we're done with things in bold,
so we back out of our most recent tag.
Finally, we'll add the word "democratically" and a period.
This depends on how our lexer works, but remember that our definition for word
was sort of anything that's not whitespace or angle brackets,
so this period will be part of the same word.
Then it will be the responsibility of our graphics library to do things like wrapping
when we get to the end of the page to decide what bold looks like.
And then to display the image back to you.
So these 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 calls produce this image.
That's how we're going to make our web browser.
While we're here, Nelson Mandela was actually the first South African President
in a fully representative democratic election,
and he went on to win the 1993 Nobel Peace Prize, plus a host of other honors.